okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about incremental
development in most language we have a
variety of topics today okay first up
names and design of the curry operator
reversed function so here we have your
last suggestion and then there is some
code that if you evaluate then we
complete examples the disick this code
uses curry operator reversed so the yeah
so our current idea is to make curry to
have this structure of first having the
number of arguments and then the
function in a separate pair of brackets
and then operator would do what curry
was doing before and we have reversed
which is a separate function so curry is
curried well we will dis yes there is a
question of whether we want to support
still the old syntax of support we could
but I mean in this case if we're using
reverse to past participle this should
be curried
so that would end up being
okay what will we call it if it wasn't
so I mean this is turning F
I mean we obviously have the term sub
value in our language although it's not
perhaps our finest term but people
understand what it means
all right so operator operator since
it's very nice it reads very well but it
has something we were worried about the
generality of this name have we probably
asked other people about it I only
concern is that whether we actually need
will need that in the future at some
point when you actually have nice
operator algebra also on differential
operator stuff like that whether we need
that term but well I think differential
operator is a fine thing for a
differential operator about the general
algebra operator algebra causing it free
operators well Jose would be a shooter
for example how would you express the
Schrodinger equation currently well I
mean you might use this operator thing
here I mean cuz right now we have you
know for the okay so let's look at how
these play together
okay so right now we have del so I could
say del X square plus y squared XY
whoops what is that doing
how does del work I think you mean grad
or death
oh yeah yeah I do mean that well in this
case probably grad the gradient of a
scalar okay yes
my thinking machine isn't problem okay
so now we would do operator so what we
do we if we did this operator grad XY
I'm not mistaken that would just work
why didn't that work why doesn't that
just work operator takes the number of
arguments for right so it would be grad
comment yes XY needs to be in a separate
pair of brackets
okay all right so do you saying operator
grad of that of that yes that makes
sense right
I mean the only question would be if
we're doing operator algebra stuff would
we in fact want to UM would we want this
X Y which of course you don't usually
ever mention in the operator algebra
stuff it's just sort of implicitly
assumed if I'm not mistaken would we
want that somehow in the first argument
the truth is that I don't see a way of
having a super general operator algebra
that fits the needs of everything I mean
if we are in quantum mechanics we will
have something which I don't know yet
what it is but something that is adapted
to that right I mean really a problem
comes from the fact that all of this
should be expressed in terms of
functions so we shouldn't talk about an
expression with X and then have to give
the variable X we should have the Grad
or function of X Y comma X square plus y
squared something like that what do you
mean when here I mean especially in this
form you you are committing yourself to
the variable names x and y inside the
operator form but we're an operator
should be applied to a function and not
an expression so I understand that okay
I see we're saying this should be a
lambda effectively here yes I mean quite
itself should like like our like
derivative right you know license got
your can of worms it says because you
know the slot enos of coordinate systems
is very weird right like r and theta two
those correspond to you know the concept
of those as slots is really strange
I mean tensors okay this this is where
we get into the same kind of worms of
coordinate systems and I think it's just
a big notational can of worms because
like a tensor the slots of a tensor
cannot be I well I guess okay can they
meaningfully be R Theta slots you have
to name it you have to tell somewhere
that you are using their deepwater
coordinates yeah so normally in normal
tensor notation if I say team you knew
those coordinates I mean there's a
coordinate system and it can be in you
know one of many coordinate systems that
those slots exist although am i green
very confused no you're right every time
that you do tensor calculus you have to
specify in which chord
system you are working and what people
typically assume is that they have one
and they have expressed everything in
that one and they just don't mention it
is that right right but that's a little
different than saying everything is a
function I think
I think this is a bit like I have a
sphere and then I represented in this
way or that way
once you have decided how to represent
the tensor in some coordinate system
then you have functions or a trace of
functions you know well arrays of
functions are another can of worms
because the index there
what index is that if it's a if it's a
four vector and the one two three four
of the four vector anyway but I don't
think that's okay let's come back to
this
I mean I'm what is my okay go ahead
my point is that I don't think operator
is going to help in any way doing tensor
calculus or anything else and because we
already talked in many places about
operator forms somehow we have already
used up the name operator I think yeah I
agree but I don't understand why we want
this rather than operator IC because we
can't do this we have to have it be
carried all the way right we need an
argument to specify the number of
arguments or if we want a permutation
because we are carrying the second right
something's asking on the live stream
what is current mean it means what we're
just saying so in this case we're saying
Caray of three F X Y that will do
nothing
I see what is the count there so the
count is the first element there is the
actual function itself right that's a
command I've written there somewhere
that in Disney notation one has this
feeling that it it one is missing
yeah I understand this is a like three
is I mean the alternative would be a
Curie F comma three of X Y Z that's the
nice thing we had before
yeah I'm what's wrong with that there's
nothing wrong but if we have carry of F
comma n then we should have an operator
form of career and that would be curry
of N applied I know that which is fine I
think that's fine I am perfectly fine
with with these two I mean there may be
some people have made some reservations
about the default for the second
argument I think the current default is
confusing and if we separate the
function into operator and carried and
it became becomes a lot nicer okay fine
so then what is the operator form of
operator the operator form of operator
like the operator form of curry is okay
you've got a different thing for the
operator form of operator if we go if we
do as meet both curry f bracket I'm
sorry free bracket F bracket and
simultaneously F comma 3 then Korean
operator are absolutely identical except
for the fact that operator has a default
for the second argument while curry is
terrible that's the only thing so if we
write operator
so it's interpretation of the one arm in
case okay so what's the one argument
case of operator of F yes that's
equivalent to operator of s comma two
one
it's me it's meaning it's waiting for
two arguments and it's going to reverse
them which is what we are ways to or in
most cases we do with operator forms so
to try now XY
okay although in most of our operator
forms I mean if I say something like you
know sort by you know length and then I
do you know whatever I do here I'll sort
by you know even queue or something
um and I do this right then so that's
equivalent to sort by list cannot even
queue so you see we are reversing them
no I understand that I understand that
but what what's different is the head is
here right the point is that the way to
use the operator form is to say my op
equals operate of F X and that thing is
then applied to Y so you would you would
almost never write it the way it is here
but so this would be operator sort by
even queue and then this right
I just think it's weird that it has to
carry the speed sin and the only reason
it has to do that is so that operator I
mean if you require that document then
you could not Curie do it I mean at the
moment we can say operate of F we can
use operate of f of X and operate event
where x and y and that's why I think for
these for these cases the curried form
is the more useful one so you're saying
we've got that and we apply it to X and
those stats that's how our operators
work right I mean every one of our
operator that reverses arguments could
be constructed in this form it's
operator of sort by comma even you
listen okay I see I see I see
so you're saying operator of sort by is
the thing that is turning it into an
operator form then you're giving its
arguments okay well let's look at
reversed then ways through this I don't
think I have examples there but it's
very simple just reversed of F X Y and
now reversed takes all arguments in one
go exactly
I mean that's a different kind of enema
that's useful by itself
notice that okay but how does it play
with all these others so well you can
put an operator inside reversed sure
okay reversed behaves as a function that
has its arguments reversed right and
presumably you can say that you only
want to reverse two of the arguments
correct so if I say comma Z here and
then if I say common to there having
done that but we could do that we should
do that because we don't want options
reversed for example yeah that's a good
point yes I mean there's even an
argument that the automatic form of a
verse that's a stupid idea no we should
just give the number to a number of
elements to reverse in a take spec
basically yes I think um
okay let's come back to the operator
thing we got three names here that are
all a little bit different in character
which I don't like very much
we've got curry which is a totally
obscure name I mean it's an inside joke
not joke but an inside thing basically
we've got operator which is a nice you
know understandable name except that it
seems more general than C what bothers
me is the way that we're having to do
you know this this currying in of things
okay the difference between operator and
curry right now it's just interpretation
of the one argument case for curry it's
a it's a it's an operator form of curry
itself
yeah and for operator it delicious
default second argument so in a sense
the one argument case of operator
hysteria two argument case
okay what if okay to make a somewhat
radical proposal what if we added the
word function here so we said does that
help us will incur it function the first
argument is not going to be a function
which reads a bit strange when the
reversed function makes a lot of sense
because we already have reverse in
various ways but for curly and operator
form I don't think it's necessary
and if we use form even though it's
overlapping with sentinels curried form
and operator from form fell for park
setting yes it has its own spelling
because do we have many other forms yeah
I don't like that very much
an operator doesn't really have a past
participle operated but we always say
operator form I know and we call it
operator and have that be see the thing
is this operator thing is doing
something particular and special which
is its flipping the argument order in
the default case and again you're
against having it go operator of F comma
Y applied to X well the problem is where
do we put all the information in the
second argument of operator what
information is it that we need imagine
this cases in which we have to carry two
arguments like my part no I don't even
know what operator does in that case so
the operator form hat carries two
arguments so it may be good to look at
our current page for curry to see
they're all the power that there is in
the second argument
yes so there for example how do we
imitate that case with curry oh sorry
this case of MANPAD yes original idea
was to have an something called curried
curry sorry in in percentage that can
simulate all possible by the forms and
yeah
no I understand I know that curry can do
that can do many things do we help page
for Clara here it's in system I did only
in 12:1 oh no it's it's in it's right
here
so so what what is being proposed here
is to rename curry to operator and
having exact same syntax and then we do
something different slightly different
with curried sauce
mainly that it has a curried form
exactly yes I mean my main concern about
what we're seeing here is that the one
argument from curry of f everybody would
expect that to be the curried form of F
and it is not sorry so again Roman
well the this curry of F the second
usage line everybody would expect that
to be a curried form of F but it is
something that also sweet flips around
arguments and does funny things and so
that is my main reservation against the
default second argument and then if we
have if we start with the first usage
languor if F comma end and curry of all
things should have been operate the form
and so we end up with the current
proposal of having curry of n of F as
the natural operate the form of curry
and disordered yes all right so the
thing that is a bit bizarre is the the
two argument ism of operator that we're
you know that the default is this but if
I would go for example like this it
would do something totally random right
why is operator why should operator be
so to argument again because the default
case in the default case we try to
imitate it what we do in the vast
majority of cases
in okay is there some way to reflect
that on the name I mean I'm not
suggesting you know that's not a good
name but um well should the function be
named after the general case or after a
special case with default argument I
it should be named after the special
case probably because
but let's see are you proposing that
there's be a second argument here that
specifies the curie spec basically here
well that yes that's that's the that's
the design I mean that the default the
second argument specifies exactly how
many arguments you want to twist in
which way that's what what carried us
now the certainty force she was each K
use case but the default second argument
of operator is 1 comma 2 which is the
same default there's no 2 comma 1 2
comma 1 so yes which is the same default
as the cons correct function I know
and this might microwave is the most
most useful default I agree with you but
my concern is the word operator sounds
more general than something that does a
2-1 flip
yes is there standard term for that -
one I mean that there are there are
Combinator's that have have this
behavior like this BC W but I'm not
they're not not very widely known so I'm
not sure we should should name it after
one of those you realize that
combinations are 100 years old next year
yes oh yes
1920 um so we should have time in
whatever we absolutely should have
Combinator K Combinator s I mean I think
we have um I agree and I have lots of
ideas about those and all you do well I
mean we must ability we need we need a
we need a binary operator we need some
some nice syntax all right we don't want
to have nested square brackets so we
need a left associative binary operator
didn't that get specified I mean don't
we I mean the left of sources that we
have left associative binary operators
but none of the symbols there is one
that you want to use for for combinatory
application I mean we decided to have
that discussions at some other point not
to overload this meeting but well it's
basically left it what is it called I
mean it's because we Celeste's left T
and there's a left triangle operator and
there are all kinds of no I don't care
what the operator I mean the operator
could be some kind of circle thing with
it with some waiting on one side that's
fine I mean I would say that the a
circle with with some kind of slightly
filled on one side would be a reasonable
way to express this which is kind of a
compromise I think but the issue is what
is the thing called so we have well that
the standard name is combinatory
application
it is a form of application but it's not
I mean it's the same that we use for
example iron application for that we
don't have a name for this it just does
what it does but you just don't have a
name for you know for this thing because
I mean this because it's a constructor
of the language and not it's not an
operator I mean this is this one is but
this one is this one is composition but
composition is kind of the other way
around from application but the add sign
itself is not an OP not an operator it's
a special form right but why is this
thing an operator why it was the well
this is just the infix form of ordinary
transfer I know it just combinatory
application why isn't there just an
infix form of combinatory application
because it associates the other way
around
now I understand it but assume like we
can have a form you assume that it was
something like okay so we should have we
shall find we should find the symbol I
mean now that we have unicode we
shouldn't really know I agree that the
fact that we haven't needed it in how
many years you know 30 years suggests
that we should have it work with unicode
and hopefully something like that is
fine but we should but the default
should be a nice a nice graphical thing
all right like like you said right but
so all we have to do then is define like
we have the @ sign it doesn't represent
there's no function in the language that
corresponds to add sign is just a
syntactic form
yeah but here that's not what we want we
want it to be a proper operator that
passes into a left associative
combinatory application without any
meaning because most of these Combinator
expressions have infinite evaluation
changed so we have to be very careful
about evaluation so this is just purely
typesetting right it will not do
anything
how would you make it do something you
say a combinatory you know Combinator
evaluate or something yeah you would
have to have some very controlled
application because I mean you the
evaluation automatic whether it's
leftmost in the most or parallel or and
in in most cases you don't want to
evaluate it think of the fixed point
Combinator or so that we just explode if
you try to do anything so so you want to
use it only for certain transformations
and the the end of this chain is not an
actual argument it's just another
Combinator right yes combinators do not
have variables right right whether they
are constants you so you can you can
have other terms but you don't usually
use them I mean like Church numerals
don't use constants they just well they
use they start with K or SS I said kind
of constant in an inner position I
understand but it's still just a
Combinator yes um it's is it clear that
here we need a nested expression and not
some sort of string that can be
manipulated faster oh I think what we
want to do absolutely when we when we do
this we will have something that says
you know Combinator and then you can
type SK SK whatever it is right how do
you but you have to put brackets in
somewhere here well I mean no
parenthesis you use parenthesis for
cooking understand T the for like your
expressions we should have something
which is essentially a and I think we've
got code for this I mean there's a
person who works with Todd for a while
doing these yeah I mean that's
straightforward I mean you would turn
this into a nested form with the
combinatory application binary operation
it's not okay with this thing so if I
didn't have those parens I would just it
would nest with a less left right that's
I see it's not an NRI operator so it's a
binary it's very much about
for it so you're saying that there's a
binary operator which says combinate to
Combinator apply or something which is
just a binary left associate which has a
form that is left associative that well
why don't we just implement this Roman I
mean we can do this we just yes all its
I mean whether we want to say apply we
should find a nice symbol and I know you
already have left associative binary
operators without meaning so you can
just duplicate that code sorry I'm still
confused
is it clear that expanding that string
into a very nested thing is is more
efficient the result is going to be less
efficient to manipulate right I think
it's just efficient to type because in
Combinator's you don't want to type
anything it's just like the
multiplication signing in calculus which
which you don't want to waste time
typing and since we need something if
you write it out in purpose in text and
something like Combinator or combinate
Combinator expand or so is very nice
just to for input write in that way we
would be able to say if we just had a
thing called Combinator we'd be able to
say something like this and that would
be by default the K Combinator yes
that's a possibility if we don't want to
name them all right but we might want to
name them well we could yes I mean we
could call it we should we should
look the Combinator K could typeset you
know it could really go all the way back
and it could be this you know Gothic
whatever it is why not I mean yeah but
then common it a cake and just types it
that way
just like this thing can conduct in a
certain way and it may or may not I mean
the question what all this Auto expands
is a difference I mean that it could be
that that doesn't auto expand and it's a
sight question is because you cannot
just put any left or there right so it
gives an error yes I mean if you do
roman numerals and you put a J in there
it's gonna give an error yes the UM I
mean we are and I don't know didn't
reminisce Molly and have every letter of
the alphabet in his in his bird calls I
don't know I mean certainly things like
I mean they're they're conventional the
Y Combinator that there's a J Combinator
as I recall that's fairly that's fairly
not well known the AI Combinator
obviously um
we should implement this we should we
should have certainly before I mean
which kind of means we have to hustle
because we we need it before I don't I
was trying to find when Sean Finkel
originally published his paper and I I
don't think I succeeded in finding that
out I only know it was 1920 Shran Finkle
did not have a happy time after that
unfortunately the basic principle people
worked on common is they either go
completely bonkers or they lead the most
minimalist lives you can imagine um at
least that's my generalization about
Combinator's um quite might be wrong but
I have a few examples of that at least
um ok no we really should do this though
really relation to this let me let me
save this someplace um any but Devon do
you know where I should save this stuff
we have a I couldn't think of anywhere
else besides miscellaneous but that
being said it might be a good idea to
have our own ILD folder or like a
functional programming folder yes okay
um well that's okay let's let's do
something for functional programming I
agree I'll just put notes okay all right
so Roman do you think you could you
could okay so I I'm proposing that the
that the operator be a circle with a
little um I mean it'd be nice if it's a
unicode character I guess do we think it
should be it should be our own custom
unicode because otherwise it's gonna get
messed up yes I mean I'm concerned Lee I
mean eat I might also have some interest
in this because I've had previous
discussions with him and and Jose
probably so it's something we can just
discuss among ourselves and then as soon
as whatever it's a noble thing we can
come back here what I would propose is
that I mean small circle on its own I
think is a is a meaningless binary
operator as I recall
that what we did yes is it binary I
don't even know if it's binary um it
seems to be an array is it even a point
no I would say no I think it is an
operator oh okay okay yes it's an NRI
operator so although we have we have
something like left to your left
triangle which already is left
associative so we just use we just work
with design to always Eric about whether
days perhaps there's something in the
history of mathematics that this is
suitable Singh suitable symbol for that
well that seems to be Emery again okay
but is this the right way around for a
if that was the symbolism here
I think it should also convert into two
nested to properly bracketed like power
thus for example what do you say try
power XYZ
so now if you do input fallout do what
the input form or full form you see it
introduces another one now I'm not sure
that it's on the right side the contact
site no this is left associated should
left associate so it will yeah I agree
it should do that it should but it
should print right like every left
associative operator I mean like rule is
an associative operator right rule has
an association there that is that is
right associative again like that but
it's still prints like this which is
what this should do makes sense
so does this mean anything Roman or is
this a pure combinatory combination
thing other words if I apply it to
something as a sub value type thing does
it evaluate or not I mean that's that's
really a tricky question because we I
mean certainly certain forms can be
evaluated like s X Y Z or K X Y which
but in general you don't want to just
blindly start evaluating look I would
propose the following I would propose
that this thing like our composition up
here okay
composition just sits there without
doing anything until it's applied to
something right so similarly when it's a
pure Combinator expression it just sits
there and you can do will have all kinds
of operations that act on the Combinator
expression but then if you apply it I
don't see why it shouldn't just go ahead
and and compute in this particular case
so if this was applied to
something what I would is no notion of
applying because it's already a plug
application and there are some easy
cases like if you have K X Y or s X when
I said that would with a but even that
if you do that on the outside then you
might still lead much the leading to
infinity valuation change so we might
need some functions to control the
amount of you know I understand that
when you have a classic Combinator I
completely understand that I mean the
the but I'm talking about if you have
just a random function from the system
in there you could perfectly well do
that right I mean cuz you could the
issue with the the issue of the
Combinator's is I mean I I just had them
actually in some recent blog post of
mine but I also have them in them you
know in general just to see I had some
nice Combinator's as I recall
yeah I mean these are these are general
this in this case what I did here was I
did s of
yeah so in this case what I was doing
was a service of Esav so I was doing the
application explicitly like that yes
sense
um I mean we should obviously have a way
to transform those Combinator
applications into the square bracket
notation
becomes becomes unreadable so we really
need that binary operators well okay
let's look at a sample here okay I agree
that that's not in the that is that is
questionable in terms of readability I
don't know whether it would really help
very much to just say SMS of s of K of K
of s of s of whatever it is right yummy
damn usually much fewer parentheses well
because you have because you're
representing it using writes a good
associate if right yes so in this case I
wonder if I can get this sum
you
right and the problem is these rules
when infinitely applied often loop yes
okay so there's a typical example so
what you're saying is that's a huge mess
which I completely agree with look at
that creature okay so you say if we were
to represent that with a binary operator
I mean if I looked at this thing and I
say what's the tree form of this thing I
forgiveness sake oh because it's all in
the head right it's all that the most of
the action here is in the head
how do I even do this what we should
probably have a tree form that goes into
the head but your point is that what we
need is something which goes from I mean
I would claim that as soon as you apply
to anything it's going to have to turn
it into brackets because otherwise okay
let's have a separate meeting about calm
yes it'll be nice to it will be nice to
actually nail that down um okay let's
come back we're back from the land of
Combinator's okay so right now okay
we're back to this operator thing okay
okay
the problem is we don't want to use up
the word operator for this fairly
specific thing
I mean something based on the word
operator will be really nice
and that's a stupid word
you
you
these are all silly words operator rised
now we'll end up with operationalized um
yeah go ahead
what's the general consensus about using
form in this I mean mostly it's used to
input output but we already have some
forms which are not like home a form I
can't even imagine what is long form no
that's crazy
I mean we we almost
rucifee was formed for typesetting
yes and I could imagine you know like
even for our Combinator's we might want
something that's called operator form of
the Combinator's as a okay what would it
look like if we said operator form it
doesn't really help anything because
it's really it's like reversed okay is
there any other way we can decorate the
word operator
what does it really do explain what it
does it turns that it makes an operator
form in which this argument
Curry's the function ants but it swaps
the arguments so yeah okay but that's
that's in the that's in the category of
I mean okay what about swapped
that doesn't really help because it's
got currying as well and that seems to
be the name for reversed not for a
praetor that's pretty weird
um I mean carry something with Kari
curry Romans looked with curry for way
too long most people in the world have
think it's an Indian you know okay yes
um I wonder if we search on the web how
far we have to get I'm just curious if I
did I if I did a web search for the word
curry I wonder how far I have to go I
wonder whether you can either tell which
one it is
oh come on what's it doing here well
okay fair enough
those people were okay we didn't have a
single not a single one of these is the
curry in our sense old Haskell um did
you know that curry college was founded
by an ancestor of Haskell curry the
there's a piece of trivia for you okay
as operator that's an interesting thing
suggest to my Lucas on our live stream
is there any of the Asian for what
operator in this small way that we have
glad things in that hop
I don't think as operator helps why does
that help I mean look the issue is not
that it's being turned into our operator
that is a perfectly reasonable piece of
communication the issue is that it's
this weird two argument form which
doesn't feel very general yes I mean we
have we call them operator forms
throughout I think that for that
particular yeah but is is it for that
particular case only or do we have other
operator forms that are like for
argument functions that you generate to
something smaller Matt that yeah we have
a few my bad and they cannot just buy
things in that okay so let's look at the
operator form of take largest buy okay
so it is a two argument okay so you guys
are saying that yeah we have no idea
where to put I mean we could have an
operator version an operator thing here
where we just start accumulating
arguments Y Z W whatever oh no we have
to give the main function here
it's very unsymmetrical right I mean we
give the main function if if the second
argument of the operator thing okay
there is an uncut version of this which
would look like this where that goes
applied to W for example goes to F of W
X Z how do you know where to put it well
that would be the conventional I I know
I know I know there's no way to do that
well except that all of our actual
operator forms work that way well I can
imagine no but think of Muppet which is
the second one that's going to be don't
forget the site yes you're right and we
might want operator forms of I know
partition in which we want something
special the first third and fifth
segment okay
so is it the case that with the curry
spec that this thing here can have can
have multiple arguments in it right that
that that single bracket thing can have
multiple arguments in it true yes okay
so there's a Curry's impact that allows
that
so how would you write map at a Zachary
spec or an operator spec yeah so that
would be operator of my part and then
the second argument would be one three
two and then you can place there F comma
post or post I mean it doesn't matter
whether you put them in the same
argument or separate and then the list
so the courage spec doesn't care whether
the things are combined like that yes so
we can have arguments in the same pair
of brackets or separate and is there
should we have a way of forcing the
curry spec of forcing that to work or
not work well I mean we could require
that these be curried right and consider
it an error if they're not courage well
implementation wise it's all based in
accumulating separate pairs of brackets
into a single one okay otherwise we need
powers of definitions remember that we
don't have a pattern for an arbitrary
number of pairs of brackets so this is
both a feature and and I need for the
implementation okay okay
well alright let's look let's try going
with this operator thing let's put it in
the system let's see if people freak out
I mean yeah I mean it's still
experimental so maybe some someday
someone will think of it excellent name
for it but I like I like using this I
mean people are gonna start using it so
curry so as long as it's experimental we
have to well yeah but we're not we're
not going to be doing that you
people are we gonna break a lot of code
with the existing I mean Lucas was
suggesting this on this is not going to
work because because of the holding
issues with f of X and so on
this was a function you know you kind of
don't even need this by the time you've
defined a function you might as well not
have any of this whole structure but the
time you're prepared to define a
function here you can just say you know
map at ash you know F hash pause and
then you're done
so okay so the one thing that's gonna
fail is the one argument form of curry
if people have used that isn't going to
work anymore
right right it will have to be renamed
operator yes well that's life um we need
to go back and and fix
various things in the 1202 scription you
know 1200 marketing pages and things
like that would have to be fixed alright
let's go ahead and implement this in
12:1 and let's see what people think
about it ok I would really not like to
not have to change it again but you know
I think we've from and then Roman you're
gonna you're gonna look at this
Combinator thing yes and ok finally made
it through that first section pared I
think this is not a particularly
sensible idea what do you think I was
trying to relate it to other things like
Association map falter etc so my idea
was you go you get what I'm suggesting
here yes so something III other dare
this Jersey C data example I think
something we do frequently is this idea
of I have a bunch of objects and I want
the pairs of the object and their value
of a function and Association map does
almost that but then for example it
doesn't play well with column for matrix
form so I have the impression that we
still do this mapping
yeah I mean the very common thing that I
end up doing is I mean clearly it's not
super difficult to say hash comma F of
hash and there's a certain argument that
that idiom I think that idiom is
probably okay I think that idiom is
clear is a nothing I'm not sure this
really helps what do you think I mean I
mean one one case where this is needed
issue if you want to tabulate function
values then this is a very useful and
slightly cumbersome way to generate a
table of values yes I mean like like for
example if we say I mean if we define
these these paired things here um you
know if we were to say array of prime
comma 10 right but if we will say array
of paired prime 10 that's kind of nice I
mean it's you know it's seriously
functional programming oriented but it's
kind of nice but you see how this is
almost Association map of prime
Princeton what is it so Association map
of trying comma range time
yeah I understand for example if column
did something nice with that I think we
would use it a lot more column or column
form I think we call it column now I'm
confused if you apply column to your 335
it's easier to read yeah I understand
well that's just a trivial thing for us
to fix or even greater table I guess I
mean you could turn it into a data set
but yeah
right I mean if we set data set of three
three six that looks quite beautiful I
agree that I think column should format
something more like this probably or
something yeah I I see no reason why
columns shouldn't format that
Association column or quit the column
gives single columns why understand but
grid a percent 3 3 5 oh I see I see what
you're saying I see what you're saying
yeah I mean that obviously works right
yes yeah but that we know that works I
mean the issue is by the way
Sandra our live stream is pointing out
that um of course Association map is has
the issue that I mean it doesn't deal
with repeated keys so it's really very
different from paired in that sense yeah
good point
yes um still I think you do make great
is for two-dimensional objects and
Association is still one-dimensional so
column could give what grid is
giving well I I don't think you should
quite give that I think it should give
something which is a little bit more
like that it needs to give some definite
print form it there's no harm in it
giving some definite print form and we
should just make that work and and Chris
Carlson probably the right person to
look at that because he's working on the
data set formatting stuff so why did you
feed that to him I'm here sorry but I
was listening with one ear ah we were
talking about formatting for column and
formatting of an association in column
yeah we wanted to do something better
than nothing right right now it's doing
nothing if you feed it to a data set it
does something quite beautiful here yeah
right so the idea is to have column have
some print form there okay and we're
leaving it to you to figure out what
that print form is for now alright look
I think paired isn't totally stupid and
I think we Bab shouldn't reduce it worst
case is that um boy you've got a bunch
of uses of it here it was time to relate
it to something else for example an
operator form of nest at least we
wouldn't have operator forms for that
prima [ __ ]
nest list what would it port with its
operator Formby I mean the problem with
the reason we don't have an operator for
nest list is because oh I see it doesn't
even elide does it doesn't have any
illusion it's good old elides it would
be an s least F comein yes absolutely
and we should have that I don't see any
reason we don't have that I mean nest F
comma v of X correct that seems like a
nice sensible thing to do and then nest
F comma one would be like dirt
I understand nest I mean even go one
step further and have nest or five of f
of X well in celebration of the
centenary of the Combinator we can just
have all these functions start to
company to themselves um that seems go
weird and I would argue I mean okay so
in the case of pad the generalization um
yeah right so
Seth on our live stream is suggesting
what you also have here which is that
paired of H F X is that so in other
words that paired of rule F X would turn
into X comma no X arrow f of X
which i think is nice but then we lose
the operator form and pad should really
be defined in terms of the operator form
and you don't really need the X in there
so what I mean so yeah that's right but
I mean why do we lose the operator form
we have paired well multiple arguments
then pair of F comma H should be the
natural this happens in other functions
there are signatures that can be
expressed in the do we really need the X
inside shouldn't we focus on the
operator form we're going Combinator
crazy I mean well I mean we in a
functional language you usually don't
put the X next to the F you a pair of F
is a fun yeah like like how well you're
saying like reversed you're saying yes
yes oh boy you're saying and you did
define an operator form there right so
you said pair of f of X and then you're
suggesting the pair of F comma rule or
rule comma F it is true that I found
these version more useful than the two
arcs
I mean I can absolutely see mapping
paired of F over things as being useful
right like if I say pair which is what
we'd essentially done before that paired
of F slash at or let's go let's go full
full whatever Knapp paired of F of this
is you know we're going functional crazy
like that
that's kind of nice that is nice
alright let's implement paired like
reversed so represents a form of F in
which it's paired with its argument now
notice that that's only a one arg form
you know that's F monadic F so to speak
we could actually at your age in the
second argument after F why do you want
in the second argument not the first
argument it's it seems this wrapping
functions that we would use in other
places like in ER and distribute and
other things that put at the end winder
you do it after you have mapped with F
yeah fair point all right let's
implement that okay I like this okay
let's see whether it very quickly we can
go over these oh boy so yes so I think
this is a great idea it's just that I
don't think this is restricted to data
set this is an operation that could be
performed on anything and what is this
thing this is this is how deep the
mapping goes this is a map yes this
mapping across different levels it's
just that the defining place is the
Leafs of an array I understand so in a
sense if we had a named level you know
levels were designed a long time ago
and -1 is is a purely structural
definition but if we had something that
said map um
f data set let's say I'm not suggesting
this is necessarily right something like
that
right absolutely so far down it goes
exactly in that direction naming the
levels
um and Genesis on our livestream is
suggesting input/output as a named
repaired I think we want it to be more
like paired because it's an operator
form that applied like reversed sorry
what were you suggesting down here yes
what I'm suggesting is introduced
something that is it's a naming of
levels like least level minus one so
look only at the list of levels and
count minus one I understand and this
well you're saying yeah you're saying
overhead you're saying look only at the
head list consider only the head list we
might be saying map F X and then only
the head list level minus one right
lists are so important that they deserve
their own structural functions and so
far we only have our a depth versus
depth so what do you do for data set
where it see the list or Association
well we would have to name it this goes
into a bit like allowed heads directions
yeah I mean so what are we trying to
achieve here I mean in other words this
the blind version of this where you're
spraying the whole you know I mean what
I would have thought we more want okay
what I'm trying to do is to make
functions that operate on a data set
that do not use the that do not require
inside the data set functional
programming stuff you know what I'm
saying so in other words right now you
know we have some random data set um I
don't know let's pick uh well we can get
make a data set from from this for
example
okay so now if I say that you know
select even queue for example that's a
bad well yes fine select even queue
right I'm going to get that
okay but the question is how would I do
that if I was not well let me give it a
I need a deeper example but how would I
do that how would I do that select
operating on the data set at a
particular level I mean I've got a way
to do it using these sub value things
but is there an external function
application way to do it Chris you're
the expert you should know I am NOT the
expert on computations as datasets Jose
is data sets should behave like standard
arrays from the pan from a structural
point of view so I would expect that
math indicating 11 that's the same thing
but it's truly obscure I mean because
it's got a glue levels back together
again and all kinds of things like this
but I think the difficult point in in
increase request is that he doesn't want
the levels counted from above he wants
levers content from below because he
wants the leaves no matter how deep they
are in the various places ya understand
that point and that thing that comes up
we don't have anywhere in the system for
lists I understand you're saying array
depth is a way where it's looking at a
depth but only for array like constructs
exactly but we don't have a level spec I
mean going down that number of levels
it's like well you can just count them
and see how far go down it goes but
going up is the complicated thing I
worry that it's just full of bugs I mean
it's just like map at level -1 is very
rarely useful because it's so structural
and it ends up you know mapping wrapping
itself around all kinds of weird things
we're not going to solve this problem
right now let's just have a very quick
look in the tiny amount of time remains
only one more comment I think the day
the new thing was
that is that they are naturally rugged
objects well in the rest of the system
we have the tendency to work with
rectangular objects right self is
pointing out the query lets one do
exactly this thing and he's right yeah
he's absolutely right
I just never used query but Seth is
writing a book about this and he's gonna
tell us how to use all this stuff yeah I
I mean I honestly I'm I'm that's
completely correct I mean if I just said
query of select even queue of percent
345 I should get the right answer yes I
do
I just don't think in terms of query
because I because we invented the sub
value syntax first um
yeah yeah I mean I also think um right
query needs to come out of the shadows
which it hasn't for me yet um so the
topics are two minor geo related things
this one we discussed long
some time ago a way of getting from a to
your position array lists of your
positions and the names we proposed
we're rich on some points but I don't
really like them because they sounds too
geometry like and I wanted something
more powerful and generalize about the
Java vectors etc so we pull over
yeah I was proposing these convention of
saying I want a list of your positions
or at the oppositional list so there
will be these five cases list your
position the position list then let's
list placed in various places
yowee and what function you feeling this
- it's it's a method for extraction from
the position objects and your vector
objects and a little bit list list the
electron acceptor determines that this
arises and they want to convert them
into list of individual position I know
yeah and we don't have neither threat
nor flattened work well well enough
right I mean I would I would think
factoring that concept I don't like it
very much um I don't like this I do not
like this I do not like this I don't
like this I mean we could do something
like this
where we're basically giving the head
head list so to speak
list of geo positions where you're
giving the the heads in the correct
order that's not totally silly I mean
it's it's a lot by the time I saying
list list list geo position list that's
pretty weird
this might work if we don't have any
sort of threading of properties I see
well that's my first take is that we
could we can factor this by by just
naming the heads there um we should talk
about how flatten works this seems like
one that might be simple yes this was
just to tell you that we changed their
behavior of how signs which I consider
back well you mean the clock has gone
back past before midnight type thing
what does it do well it's so so the fact
that before in order to have a negative
specification will require the signs in
the three places now it's only the first
one which is what standard it's done
usually so that photo ICO that bonkers
I mean if somebody gives that you should
convert it into this but you should also
allow just a single minus sign exactly
exactly so before we were returning what
it's there in the first line which
wasn't correct that's bonkers yeah I
agree with you there's documented
carefully but I agree with you yes yes
and then one user has had suggested the
opposite direction the fact that we
can't return from DMS history's signs so
I have added this plus minus in the same
way that we had e w and NS to the port
signs then there is this plus minus and
then it will give a sign
okay oh I see - to give the sign
explicitly Experion if it's plus exactly
yeah
so the important thing was to have the -
rather than an east or west and sorry a
west or south I don't know I see I see
you mean whether to give a plus or
whatever exactly will suppress it we
don't suppress east or west
so I mean why not give the plus exactly
yes that's my what do they do for right
ascension and things like that isn't
that that's handled through mixed
quantity mixed units but does right
ascension have a plus and a minus
well it returns quantities with numbers
and the units are yes the numbers have
their their Sundays their signs and
therefore the conventions that we have
right now well this seems okay to me um
all right so we got to come back next
time we might need to talk about geo
position list list which doesn't sound
quite right and we need to come back
next time and talk about deficit mapping
functions and let's implement these
functional programming things and see
how we how we go and we're forking off
another meeting specifically about
combinators and we can have a little um
I am about to start researching Moses
Shawn Frankel in preparation for writing
something about the centenary of
combinators and I have this bizarre
theory about Tim I have this bizarre
historical theory let's say about John
Franco but um we'll see if it's true um
it's um anyway I mean Shawn Finkel
unfortunately ended his days very in
very unfortunate way but that's that's a
different story he was a student of
Hilbert's originally and
but I don't know how much Justin I mean
I tracked him down back when I was
writing the nks book because I wanted to
have a dates for him and that was
difficult to find okay
in any case different topic all right
well very good um oh wait a minute
Carla's saying you'd like to flag that
your position of multiple points it's
kind of weird and would be great to get
better support for it well that's what
we're trying to do here I think that geo
position of multiple points is kind of
weird but I mean here we have pointed
multiple points to all of them at the
same time right and I mean notice by the
way and I'd like to make this point that
sorry lots of points running around that
point of a list of coordinate pairs or
triples we don't have all this packing
unpacking sub value stuff for points do
we like nobody is asking for to a point
I mean that is an interesting question a
point of a list of points point of a
list of coordinates shouldn't we be able
to turn that into explicit you know a
list of points and why is that never
come up and why does it come up with
your position but it doesn't come up for
point yeah I think that's an interesting
question which might reveal that there's
some other lack of some function related
to geo position so let's so it's more
defense perhaps it's staying for some
difference is that point only supports
one level of list well your position
supports any level of lists so sometimes
you have very deep objects and all try
to convert them into let's let's discuss
this another time um all right Tokio
soon thank you all thank you to people
on livestream see you later